yo I wanted to talk to you because I
feel like correct me if I'm wrong I
remember seeing something when I was
like younger when you were uh in the
league were you throwing up your
neighborhood like ever on video like
when you were like making shots and [__]
because that never happened no okay
because I wanted to ask you about how
you feel about the driving rant [__]
because obviously the driving range is
kind of interesting and you were
obviously a young kid who came from a
serious area of La yeah got drafted into
the league I'm sure you dealt with a lot
of [__] I was just Guilty By Association
but I I mean I don't
I don't remember you know maybe off the
court but I don't remember like on the
court maybe I did you know sometimes you
get hyped you know what I'm saying like
anything happened but obviously you you
know you did a lot back then you feel
what I'm saying it was a lot we did a
lot back then and it was a lot of you
know if we had social media back then
everybody would be like have horrible
tarnished images you know what I mean
because it was just you know back in the
day like you could with no camera phone
so like whatever was cracking you know
right then and there it was what was
cracking like you have to have a video
person you have to tell somebody bring a
camera yeah you know what I mean back
then so you know a lot of people was
like not so much getting in trouble like
because I don't think John Moret is in
trouble you know what I mean like he did
some you know some stupid [__] right but
at the same time like we've been doing
like we've been doing stupid [__] for
the longest time a long time you know
this wasn't everyone now microscope yeah
yeah it's under a microscope because you
know I I was saying to uh just to my
friends man I'm you know I cried on my
25th birthday I cried on my 30th
birthday and on my 35th birthday I was
like damn dude I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna actually live you know what I mean
and so just thinking about you know that
Journey from the time I got drafted to
the time I hit 30 was just it was just a
lot
coming back home you know what I mean
having to deal with that you know being
on the road people you know just during
the season people think you saw say
something to you you know you gotta go
find them in off season and see if it's
real oh wow you know what I mean like
just wow you know what I mean and like I
think once I kind of got to go to state
you know things just start kind of like
leveling out I was like man let me
change let me change who I am and and
like I don't need to be this this is not
me you know what I mean I'm not I'm not
like I'm not like this you know I want
to be what do you have to prove like I
didn't have [__] you're a [__] you
know you're a millionaire you're on TV
every day yeah and at the same time like
bro I'm scared to die yeah
it's real out here you know what I mean
like they they shoot at athlete out here
back in the day crazy right remember
Jalen Rose got shot at why are you
shooting at Jalen Rose right who the
[__]
shoots at Jalen Rose you know what I
mean and he was on Sunset so I just you
know for me it was just like that era
was a lot of jacking you know it was a
lot of uh pressure extortion you know
the NBA players are getting extorted all
day NBA players rappers uh
musician anybody came to La it was just
not a good place to be you know what I
mean like if you got found or you was
out shopping it like if if you can stay
low cool but back then if you was you
was on the move and you get caught it I
mean you have to have mercy I was gonna
say because I I would like like
obviously a lot of the stuff is highly
back to the camera phones thing we see a
lot more of the people getting robbed on
Sunset or on Melrose and it's like yeah
that kind of [__] has always been
happening in LA but I feel like back in
the day it was really like Peak you kind
of had to come to LA and like
if you were going to move around you
really had to be in line with some guys
to make sure that there wasn't any sort
of yeah yeah that was the whole like uh
the tap in error the tap in Era people's
chains are getting took people had to
get the chains yeah you get the chain
back we gotta I mean
you know I got a couple change back from
some for some uh some rappers actually
no basketball players whose team did you
get
hey bro we don't talk like that what
label were they from I don't even know
what label I just know they're one of my
favorite you know one of my favorites uh
you know a couple rappers man just
that's just how I be you know what I
mean like a couple rappers just like
come to LA tickets and you got to think
like coming up in that game area with
the game when gang was first starting to
like break out like it was no blood
rappers
it was no Bloods famous period you know
what I mean yeah if you really think
outside of Mack 10 yeah it was Mac 10
and then and then the game and then
everybody was a blood everybody started
being Bloods you know what I mean so
imagine like
rocking with the blood that is on his on
his way up you know what I mean in L.A
so it was a lot to deal with with that
and he was the face of La for like a
decade yeah he carried the whole coach
for like a very long time yeah and and I
think it just kind of for me like
hanging with game
made me realize that okay me my plan was
me and gang rocking together I mean he
can unify the music I can unify the hoop
and then we can create this
La unified system where like we can make
it better for dudes right you know what
I mean like we can stop
all the jacking and [__] like that you
know what I'm saying like at least if
they [__] with us are they rolling
with us you're not gonna get checked you
ain't gonna get robbed you ain't gonna
get into no funny business you know what
I mean and like that was the goal is
really like once I saw that I was like
man like nip coming Don I'm coming you
know YG I'd had a couple songs but YG
was on his way you know what I mean it
was a bunch of dudes just like on a rise
and I was like damn dude uh Kendrick you
know what I mean Jay Rock was out but
Jay Rock was like on his way so like uh
I remember we did the game the Crips and
bloods gang documentary and uh I was
like man I need to put a soundtrack
together
and on the soundtrack is all them dudes
like damn their first soundtrack right I
remember how long ago was that
documentary uh I think I want to say 20
2015. no 1204 I think 2004. yeah Jesus
Christ yeah it was like 2004 or when I
got to
it was like 2004.